I did a podcast on this and where I
think it was a week and a half ago where
I really I did 30 minutes of timeline on
exactly who is saying what at what time
I'm not trying to make excuses for Trump
here I just want people to understand
the truth I'm Dave Rubin of this is the
Rubin report reminder guys you can get
all of our episodes days early and
totally ad-free at Rubin report com
and joining me today is a former Navy
SEAL the congressman from Texas is 2nd
district and author of fortitude
American resilience in the era of
outrage congressman Dan Crenshaw finally
welcome to the Rubin report it great to
be with you Dave
we've been trying to pull this off for a
long time but I guess it took it took a
pandemic to it for us to accept Skype as
the only way we could make it happen
yeah that's true I was supposed to come
through LA for my book tour as you know
we had some events planned together but
you know life happens life happens
indeed it does all right well let's
start with the stuff that we got to get
out of the way no matter what before we
get into the book and your story and
everything else which is just
coronavirus sort of where we're at I'm
really curious your thoughts on the
stimulus package and the way we watched
it sort of unfold but just generally can
you talk about what it's like to be in
Congress right now in a time of truly
unprecedented happenings yeah it's odd
in the same way that it's probably odd
for everybody else you're trying to
continue doing your job hopefully you
still have your job and but you're
trying to do it from home you're trying
to to to be as effective as you were
before but you're but you're doing it
from home and that's that's difficult
more psychologically than logistical e
we can make an app in logistic way our
office is still operating as normal the
there's there's the frustrating thing
about how this is played out
from the Congressional standpoint is is
how the partisan games didn't really
stop and whereas we maybe thought they
would we
I had some hope that they would mostly
because they they were stopping to an
extent I'll never forget Chuck Schumer
on TV that Saturday and late February
talking about how bipartisan this rescue
package was going and it was going well
good talks he said he said surprisingly
good bipartisan talks and then it all
blew up the next day and he quickly
shifted tax and and and and went right
along with Pelosi s demands of this
crazy progressive wish list ultimately
the package went through days later
after millions of jobs have been lost
but ultimately went through and it was
basically the same package anybody who
argues otherwise is being totally
intellectually dishonest you know the
changes were minor and could have been
agreed to that weekend prior that was
extremely disappointing that was also a
turning point I think I think we all
noticed a turning point right then that
came from the left-wing media and that
that turning point was Trump is to blame
for millions of deaths for now that's
right that was the new that was the
that's been the new narrative and it
hasn't stopped
in fact it shifts slightly okay you know
you saw it shift from from saying hey
there's the Trump's travel restrictions
from China won't really travel
restrictions it was you know he could
have done more all right well that's a
dishonest talking point because the
reality is the people coming from China
after January 31st were American
citizens or green card holders so now
you're gonna have to explain to me why
we shouldn't be repatriating our own
citizens okay these are just really
disingenuous or remarks now the new
talking point is that they didn't do
anything in February okay fine so the
travel restriction was good we agree
with that even though we didn't at the
time and even though Democrats were in
charge they never would have put those
were travel restrictions then fine Trump
didn't do anything to February except
for except deny the whole thing again is
this really an honest talking point you
know could it with 20/20 hindsight could
we have done more yes but what the facts
that we had at the time I questioned
what what exactly you think they should
have done more PPE production and
ventilator production more testing
production I agree with all that
I just don't think it's I just don't
think it's reasonable to be looking back
in time and saying you
made this decision differently than I
would have made this decision is that
true is that the toughest part of doing
what you guys have to do in terms of
preparing for something like this
because right now the hindsight thing is
just driving me crazy when you hear it
from the media that oh suddenly they're
saying everybody knew this was coming in
February and it's like you know there
were I think three possibly four
Democratic debates in February the last
one in February I believe was February
25th it was one of I was not mentioned
in any of them it wasn't mentioned until
the one where they only had Biden and
Bernie in a room alone because of
coronavirus that was already into March
so you see everybody it's like yeah now
that we see the score of the game yeah
we can tell you everything that you did
wrong before but that's not really how
you can prepare as a government a
hundred percent true I I'm about to
release a video on on this exact thing I
did a podcast on this and where I think
it was a week and a half ago where I
really I did 30 minutes of timeline on
exactly who is saying what at what time
I'm not trying to make excuses for Trump
here I just want people to understand
the truth and you made another good
point I don't even bring up that point
my timeline of like they weren't talking
about this nobody was talking about this
in late February Pelosi and de Blasio
we're telling people to go celebrate the
Chinese New Year go out don't be afraid
and I'm not blaming them they had the
same set of facts that we all did I
don't think they're responsible for
people's deaths either I think I I think
this is a bad situation that we didn't
quite expect I also point out you know
in Italy they didn't shut down their
society until March 10th Spain not until
March 14th
that's way later than February as it
turns out you know we did our 15 days to
slow the spread on March 16th Iran
didn't even start until April 4th Sweden
still hasn't started and probably never
will you know it's just these are really
disingenuous attacks and as it pertains
to something like PPE even with
hindsight you know it's not obvious that
the PPE shortage is going to be there
it's not like I think people simplify
what information government officials
truly have and are capable of having
it's not like it's not like there's this
final
tally of 95 mass and the government just
knows what they are and knows what
they'll need well no I mean hospitals
are also responsible for stockpiling in
Houston we're well stockpiled maybe
because we've been through a lot of
we've been through pandemics before
we've been through hurricanes before our
possible system operates a little bit
differently then maybe another hospital
system but doesn't feel they need a
bunch of n95 masse that's not
necessarily the federal government's
fault again if we really want to point
fingers really want to go down this road
I will point you to all the fact
checkers that have confirmed that it's
really the Obama administration that
didn't replenish our national stockpile
then 195 mass after the h1n1 virus but
should I really blame them I mean that's
another question should I really be
playing blaming the Obama administration
what crystal ball do they have they
spent it on radiological protection and
things like that you know there's no ill
intent here and now I will also point
out that our hospital systems have been
strained but not broken nobody has been
denied a ventilator
unlike in places in Europe why because
well it turns out our profit-driven
health care system has an excess of
things like ventilators and ICU beds I I
went through the numbers on this on a
per capita basis
the US has way more orders of magnitude
more ICU beds and ventilators than any
of these Western countries or countries
in Europe any of them including Germany
and that's a product of our health care
system it's an imperfect health care
system I wish it was different in a lot
of ways but socialized medicine means
less supply because you're basically
saying price controls and people need to
understand these basic facts as we as we
judge what could have been done and what
should have been done so speaking of
what could have been done what should
have been done can you just explain a
little bit about how information
actually gets to you guys like how does
it get to a member of Congress that say
in January there's sort of these initial
reports of something going on Trump does
the initial shutdown I think it was on
last day of January I think but like
when does something actually get to your
desk and how do you ask
actually decide oh now this is something
I gotta talk to somebody about or do you
pass it on to somebody and say does this
study make sense or is anyone else see
in these reports like how does some of
that information actually turn into
something actionable yeah that's an
interesting question we don't have a
whole lot of secret lines of information
that the public doesn't have oftentimes
members of Congress are really operating
off of the same set of facts that most
people in the media are or most members
of the the public the difference is we
have sets of professionals that we can
rely on to sift through all of the
information and and and place that
against prior policy compare that
against prior legislation and in talk
about it in legislative terms this is we
we we have I just have a team that helps
me do that so that you know I I'm not a
I'm not a journalist trying to do it all
myself and so that's a huge advantage as
far as sifting through the information
and making sure that we get it correct
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell